the parking ticket machines on products
ventsislav square accepts euro coins
along with Czech crowns but Czech
membership in the eurozone is a topic
that's been put off for years that's
just fine with former Czech president
václav Klaus he never misses an
opportunity to criticize the EU and its
democratically elected top level
politicians but what does he think the
EU of the future should look like he was
in favor of the brexit this is it's
really a victory it's a victory for all
of us but the truly European Democrats
and it's an opportunity for Europe to
finally do something important to change
helpers get from a dead end to the
future somehow now anti-eu voices in
Prague are getting louder but recent
opinion polls about the possibility of
the Czech Republic leaving the EU show
an undecided electorate wishes a toast
our German I'm not yet I'm afraid that
if the EU forces us to accept more
refugees then more people will want to
leave the EU no we'll stay in the Czech
Republic is an important trade partner
for Germany Auto Skoda for example is a
subsidiary of Volkswagen the trade
volume between the Czech Republic and
Germany is growing each year and is
currently at some 80 billion euros
annually but the key factor in this
economic boom is that both countries are
EU members that switch commands are
investing basically you can say that the
Czechs tend to be Euroskeptics
but they are aware of the economic
advantages that they have thanks to
their EU membership the Czech Republic
is very closely integrated in the EU
economy
the country exports its products mostly
to other EU Member States
just one example of that is the company
Lynette owned in equal parts by German
and Dutch investors the company makes
hospital beds and sells from 270 million
euros worth annually the domestic market
is too small for all the hospital beds
the company makes most of them are
exported to the rest of the EU
the company employs some 700 people few
who work here want to imagine what would
happen if the country left the EU
because what happened that mentally old
members accepted Czech Republic as a
country from which we can export
products by simple way because we are
working by simple and same rules as they
do only a small percentage of the
products are exported to Britain yet
management here expects the brexit to
have an impact on sales it's worried
that Britain's state-funded health care
system will come under increased
pressure with less money to buy
expensive hospital beds yes we have also
hear voices like we have now brags said
that they would be Czechs it but I don't
really think that this is something what
people want here in the country
referendums like the one the UK has just
held are not possible under the
Constitution of the Czech Republic but
the voices calling for a vote on
continued EU membership are growing
louder